(air whooshing)
- This is this is a huge
game right now of pie, right?
Perspective will solve everyone's anxiety.
(upbeat music)
[Narrator] You got your perspective.
(engine roaring)
(audience cheering)
Just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Morning everybody, and welcome
to another episode of Tea with
GaryVee on this beautiful,
Friday, March 27.
I am your host, Gary Vaynerchuk.
This is my tea party
and we are doing a tonne of Q&A today.
To recap if you're just joining,
we've started this I think on Tuesday.
We need do Monday,
do we doesn't?
- [Dustin] We do, like the first one.
Oh good, awesome.
So, actually we've done this all week.
And we're really enjoying it.
Tonnes of great questions and answers,
lot of great engagement.
Not a lot of bells and whistles.
This new zoom background
is the most bell or whistle
that we brought to the table,
but very in depth detailed
answers to business questions.
I'm gonna try to get some more today.
Dustin, do we have the first
person kind of in the queue?
Awesome, Chris, how are you my friend?
- I'm doing great.
How are you, Gary?
- I'm well where are you from?
- I'm from Minnesota.
- Fantastic, What can I help you with?
- So, a little bit of first off gratitude,
thank you for having me on,
much appreciated.
- I'm happy to do Chris.
I'm a principal of a K12
School in in Minnesota here.
And with the--
we have now have a shelter in place,
our students haven't been in
school for quite a while now.
One of the things that I'm fielding
and I'm doing my best to to support them,
our seniors who won't
be having a graduation,
won't be having would be
actually our first prom
in school history.
Some of those things
and I know kind of what
your advice might be
and I know what I've been telling them,
what more would you provide them?
What would you say to them?
- What your Chris, what
I'm sure you're doing
and it's why you said I
know what your advice is,
obviously, you're gonna
go down the empathy
and the compassion and the
perspective path, right?
- Hundred percent.
- You go down those three,
I would say the final
piece of the equation,
and maybe the value out of
this call is innovation.
One could argue that
through live streaming
and things of that nature,
you could have a virtual prom,
you could have a virtual graduation.
It would take a lot of planning
by you and superintendent,
teachers, volunteers,
parents and students.
But besides the hey,
look, thank God, we're alive
and hey, maybe we can
consider doing something
in the summer.
If some of you wanna do it
before you guys go to college.
You could do something fun
and what I love about innovation,
my head goes through so
many different ideas.
I'm like, would it be cool
to after you do all of next
year's classes, graduation,
as many seniors as want to
come back to walk, whatever,
one of the most hilarious
things of all times
would be a virtual prom.
And I think some people would get a laugh
out of that dressing up at home
and being virtual with their date
and things that nature,
you get a DJ to come in.
But it's innovation, right?
Your school could reach out
to 50 famous Instagram DJs,
all of them are looking
to do stuff right now
one of them says yes, all of a sudden,
everybody gets hyped
because they have one of the
most famous DJs in the world,
deejaying virtual prom.
So I think besides the things
that probably you and I
are connected on, based
on me hearing you say,
"I know what you're going to kind of say
"anything your vibe,"
I think innovation is the
final piece of the equation.
And that is a macro sense
that's for everybody.
This is huge game right now of pie, right?
Perspective will solve
everyone's anxiety, everyone's.
- Right.
- As long as somebody in
your family does not die
from Corona virus.
This is a blessing, no
matter even if you lose your
your business or your job in
the macro of your entire life.
If you see and you start innovating
that the second part of pie innovating,
this is gonna be an incredible
month of innovation,
where in 20 years you'll hear over dinner,
somebody telling you that their happiness
whether in a personal relationship,
whether in a business,
whether in a career happened
during the two months
of downtime during Corona.
- Well, my perspective
on this whole situation
is that it's really disrupting education.
And I believe it's in a positive way.
Right now, our teachers
have had two weeks to plan
for students working on distance learning,
and they're planning for micro,
we're looking at macro,
what is it going to
look like down the road
and how can we leverage this situation
and the knowledge that we gain
from this to change education.
I mean, Gary, I've seen your report card.
I know.
- (laughing) Sorry principal.
Hey, I get it, man.
I know it wasn't great
and I guess one of the other questions
as we look into more
of the online platform
and supporting distance learning,
I think about what can we do to support,
reach out and support our
kids with mental health
and all of that stuff
and what else can we bring,
but also taking it from
an individual perspective.
I think back even looking
at your report card,
what did you need that you didn't get
as a middle in high school kid?
What would have--
turns out you ended up just fine.
- What I needed?
What to your point,
I needed, and it was a
couple teachers along the way
that did dig in, in humanity, right?
You're a nice kid, Gary,
this is obviously you
know, that kind of stuff.
What they didn't have
the flexibility to do
was curriculum me individually, right?
And I have empathy for that.
What I needed to be
doing in freshman year.
Let me tell you why there
was no As besides Jim
the other A would have been the history
of advertising, right?
If I was in class being
taught why new coke failed,
I mean, I would have clowned
the valedictorian, right?
- Sure, right.
- And so that's that.
- Well my school is small enough
that we've added an additional class
that we call real world ready,
where they're talking about taxes,
they're doing the character
development stuff,
they're doing financial
Dave Ramsey program
all of that stuff that we can
leverage into other areas.
- Chris, let's make a deal here,
next year's curriculum,
send me an email right now.
Chris the principal in Minnesota.
It's gary@vaynermedia.
I'd love to come in and give a 45 minute
or however long the class is lecture
on real world next year on me
as a little added bonus.
- That'd be awesome man.
- It's done.
Free, inspirational and practical talks.
Looking on Twitter right now Caleb White,
Caleb widow, excuse me,
I'm retweeting you
for any newcomers to Tea with Gary.
Excuse me, tea with Gary Vee.
If you take a screenshot of this
and tweet it with a link
to the Facebook live
and say join us I will
retweet or follow you.
Brandon Baker gets a retweet,
the MZ family gets a retweet,
Shirou gets a retweet.
I'll be right with you Erica
just giving out some retweets
to James T, to Robin,
Let's this, Devin
Alexander gets a retweet,
Jase Dean gets a retweet,
Steve Hopkins I'm gonna
give a follow boom.
Steve Hopkins gets a follow, Nick See.
And Erica is with us.
How are you Erica?
- I'm doing well, how are you?
- I'm well.
I wanna say thank you
so much for doing this.
It's been a part of my morning routine.
So it's just super awesome.
- Has it been fun.
- It has and I wanna
thank the team Gary Vee
for just putting it together.
Just watching you work so hard
just to give back in a
time where people are lost.
And I mean, I'm fortunate
enough to work from home.
So I don't have to worry about that.
But it's just that to watch
something like this is amazing.
- Thank you.
- Okay. So my question
is I'm a creative person.
So I'm an industrial designer.
That's what I do for work.
I do engineering drawings
for displays to build them
but on the side I feel like
I'm a jack of all trades,
and I'm trying to figure out
how to put everything together.
I love doing graphics,
that's my poster, I'll make--
- Oh my God!
That's fucking epic by the way.
- Thank you.
- I was actually--
Damn it, I'm so pissed at myself.
I was literally about to say something
and then we got right into it,
how much I liked it.
That's so well done Erica.
- Thank you, I'm just
super, super hard on myself
when it comes to doing things
and I just don't think I'm good enough.
So that really prohibits me
from putting a lot of
stuff that I do out there.
And do you think it comes from parenting
or environment or DNA?
- I don't know.
- I actually gotta tell you.
- My parents are great,
they're super supportive,
my mom, my sisters,
everybody's great on that end.
I think I'm just super hard on myself.
- Let's try to dig for more.
You don't deal well with feedback.
If somebody said that post
is not technically sound
or I don't like it.
Does that hurt you or no?
- It hurts but then I look at okay,
can I do it better
or without that just their opinion?
- Right, and I think if you could be--
I think that's smart.
Now if you broke down 100%
of the energy typically
on can I do it better?
Was that good feedback?
Or is that just their opinion?
Breakdown 100% of energy.
Do you think it's 20-80, 50-50 or 100-0,
give me a--
- I mean, I think it's probably maybe 80%,
I mean I'm thinking I'm good enough
and then 20% whether I take
their opinion that's valid,
'cause it's more about me less about them.
- Yeah, so that's an interesting insight
because for me, it's like 92.
And I'm trying to think
about what does that mean?
What is the delta between me
when people give me feedback?
It's 90, What's your
biggest accomplishment?
- Okay.
- I they're both the
same it's _madebyerica.
- Nice one, okay.
_madebyerica,
everybody who's watching
right now.
- Oh, God.
- Yep, go on Twitter
or go to Erica's latest Instagram post
an _madebyerica,
if you are the kind of person
that sees a post like that
and thinks it's $100 poster,
that style maybe a different
one 'cause that is a celebrity.
Just let her know you're
one of those people.
_madebyerica on Twitter and Instagram.
Let this amazingly talented
young woman know that you're--
And don't go there,
let's not be like a nice
community and go there.
If you're gonna do that,
just go and say, "Hey, girl, keep going."
But if you're the kind of person
that would buy a poster like that,
especially if signed by her
1-100 for 100 bucks or so,
just let her know.
Erica, I could tell you right now,
if you're capable of making that poster,
you're capable of making
$100,000 a year minimum,
minimum selling fucking
posters you make awesome.
And when I say minimum,
you could make a million dollars a year.
- That thought is scary but,
and then I guess in a good way.
- Erica that's a really good poster.
- I know, I'm just so hard on myself.
I mean, I really like it.
I'm not gonna say that I don't like it.
But I just yeah,
even like share that
it's a big deal, I guess.
- Yeah 'cause you're insecure.
- Yeah. Oh, yeah.
- I don't want you to be.
Which is why I'm trying to figure out why.
And a lot of people have
a tonne of great parents
who are loving and sweet,
but they told them not to take risk.
Because they came from tough situations,
or they don't have the
DNA of a risk taker.
- Right, I think that's part of it.
- Could be.
I think yeah definitely
that's a good part,
part of it, I mean, I went
to school for graphic design
and industrial design.
So that was a little bit of a departure.
But that was a way where
I can combine my graphics
but still find a job.
- I get it.
The good news is the internet came along
in our lifetime Erica,
and you can do that job
and start building up Made by Erica,
and build a business, a real one.
- Yeah.
- Erica I'm telling you right now,
I want you to email me gary@vaynermedia.
I wanna commission you to
make some posters for me
for my office.
- Wow, okay.
- I'm not kidding.
I'm a nice guy and I do things,
but I take a lot of calls.
And I wouldn't say this,
I actually like that kind of style.
- Thank you.
I appreciate it so much you have no idea.
- Listen to me Erica,
you have to take my very
nice words right now
and not hear them.
And you have to take
people that say you suck
and not hear them.
Once you can't hear is
the day you start to live.
- Absolutely.
Thank you so much, I just, I yeah.
- Just please use the
serendipity of the Corona virus,
leading to be having time
to leading to this moment.
Take that in, take in this moment
and use that in three days when the energy
of this call is not here with you anymore.
And you start feeling that insecurity
because you're about to
get 87 great comments,
120 great comments and
one person might say,
"Ah, you ain't that much shit
"wait till I talk to Gary
Vee you'll see I'm better."
And if you decide to focus on that.
Versus the 87 good.
You're gonna still be brought
back to the same place.
You have to not hear the good comments,
you have to not hear the bad comments,
you have to live in a
fucking cocoon like I do.
- And tune it out, all of it.
- You know why?
- Why?
- 'Cause it doesn't matter.
- True.
- Did all those opinions of
people on your relationships,
your looks, your school,
your work, your creativity,
did all those opinions matter
if yesterday you picked up Corona
and died in a week?
- No.
- Good.
- Yeah, you're right.
- Whose opinion has value?
Why?
- I know and I listen to you all the time
and yeah, I mean, like everybody,
when is the point where it sinks in?
- And the key is, I think
what really works for me
is I'm saying that to myself
every second that I breathe,
not occasionally or when I need it.
And I'm trying to figure
out what that means.
And how do I get that across?
One of the other things I
just realized, it just hit me.
One of the reasons I don't hear anybody
is I'm too compassionate and
empathetic that for them,
knowing that they have
their own life experiences
that led them to a positive
or a negative comment.
Almost every single person,
almost every single person
that leaves a negative comment
to another human being, whether virtually
or in real life is deeply hurting inside.
- Yeah and I definitely hear that.
I definitely understand
that there's more than
just a common good or bad.
- And people are like,
oh, look they're just
jealous of your skills
and I'm like let's not even make,
let's not even demonize these people
that are trying to hurt us.
Let's be compassionate to them.
Compassion is missing.
When somebody says your
posters a piece of shit.
I'm compassionate, I'm like, man,
this fucking person stumbled
on my Instagram account
and decided to waste a minute
trying to tear me down.
The must be in such an awful place.
- Now that's true, absolutely.
I mean, I definitely see things that way.
I guess it's just different when it comes
to myself personally.
- That means you don't see it differently.
That means you understand the theory,
but you're not gonna live in it.
- Right.
(sighing) Thank you.
Thank you Gary.
There's not enough things in the world
for just everything you do
and gives everybody and for this call
there's so much value, it's not even funny
and I just really appreciate how the--
Making the best out of a situation.
- Correct.
- So thank you so much.
- You're welcome Erica, email me.
Facebook we are back.
Thank you so much for
waiting for the last hour.
I was on Instagram live for the last hour
doing Tea with Gary Vee.
Now we're back on Facebook.
And Tim thank you so much
for icing the kicker waiting it out.
Sorry for the technical difficulties,
but we improvised.
Tim were you watching on Instagram?
or you just kind
of weighing it out?
- Yeah.
Like two phones and
two computers here, so?
- You're the man, what
can I answer for you?
- Well, I got a little
bit of background here,
so you usually ask, how did you--
when did you start listening?
We're about the same vintage here.
So I remember back when my daughter
was first born, walking around listening
to Diggnation on podcast, 2006.
And a library I used to
watch that back then, 2006.
But here's the crazy thing.
So I'm gonna be pretty
vulnerable on this call
because maybe it's less for me
and maybe what other
people can get out of this.
I remember growing back then
going I really want to start a podcast
and I'm like, it's too fucking late.
What the--
seriously, same thing with Twitter.
I'm on Twitter forever,
barely do anything.
But now there's two ways to look
at my current situation, right?
It depends on framing.
I'm going through a divorce right now.
And my job--
I was chief operating officer
it was pretty high for the company.
And then that's all changed.
So on the other flip
side, it's a blank slate.
And it's not really where
I wanted to be anyway
in terms of corporate
America, stuff like that.
I'm like, I could give
a shit about the title.
I didn't care but it's like,
this is what I'm supposed to be doing
and it so we're in that
weird border, right?
Where we're not,
we're too old to be millennials
or have that kind of thing.
But we're in--
my parents are great.
But they were very much
like this is the path
you should choose and go to school, cyber,
multiple college degrees
and all that stuff.
But never felt right.
So now I'm trying to figure
out what do I wanna do.
Weird shutout, I started
baking sourdough bread
when I moved into my
apartment a few months ago.
And actually last night,
I sold my first two loafs,
and I don't even necessarily
want to be a baker.
What I'd rather do is be on
Instagram talking about that,
using that as one of the
things not just being a baker.
(mumbles)
- I guess so.
Yeah and that's probably
why I always struggled,
I have been let off five times.
- I think that's good, I
actually think that's good,
I think that's an interesting data point.
It means that you aren't capable
of completely conforming.
- (laughing) That's damn sure.
Yeah. I know, that's right.
- That's my observation.
So that I'm glad that you
gave that confirmation.
That's good, that's good, keep going.
- Yeah, I mean, so that's just
been my thing right now is
obviously financial freedom.
- Well, let's talk about it,
obviously, yeah, you just beat me to it
going through a divorce
without knowing how you saved
or what your actual situation is.
How much freedom financially
do you have to be able
to have the ability to
completely be creative
and try to figure this out?
Or how quickly do you need
to make a meaningful enough income
to fulfill your obligations?
- (sighing) Yes. I spent
the last few months
kind of burning through
a lot of that, right?
I didn't--
Look this is a process to me,
and last year if you had me on this,
I was not this guy.
And honestly, part of this,
you wanna call therapy,
whatever, it was just getting on here
because I don't like a
lot of things about myself
and I've been working really hard.
So just getting out
here and like realizing
that there's four or five, 10, whatever,
hundreds thousands of
people watching this.
I'm sweating a little bit,
but I also I like performing,
I like being in front of
people reading from people.
It's a weird thing.
- Right, which is why
you wanted to--
look understood.
- There's like this magician
performer inside of me
that wants to like get out.
But then there's other cards.
It's like, "No, you gotta
go sit at a desk job."
I'm like, "Fuck that no I don't."
So answering your question.
It's interesting, like I've got--
I actually just picked
up some consulting work
that should be able--
and still be able to have
flexibility in my schedule.
Probably be able to float
the bills for a little bit.
And that's the goal, right?
- So do you wanna build a personal brand
around your your tree.
Like the 79 things you like.
Do you wanna document the journey,
like the post-divorce man starring Tim
And it just kind of the documentation
of you finding your thing
which I've always thought
is a huge opportunity because
there's nothing easier
everyone's like, "what do I make?"
And I'm like, "The truth,
you make the truth."
You literally--
Some days it just you in
front of the camera like this,
other days you set up
your video recording,
it sends a tech-like savvy
enough with two computers
and two iPhones, so maybe
the Tuesday blog and podcast
is you just crying and saying
why you're still not over
the divorce or you're
crying out of happiness
that you're ready to be
happy and out of the room,
whatever the truth is, and then Wednesday,
it might be the making of the sourdough.
And then Thursday it might
be you showing the picture
of you selling two loaves and you saying,
"Look, this isn't really
necessarily the business
I wanna build, but I like
this and you know what?
I'm gonna fly a kite tomorrow.
So I think the
documentation of the process
has the potential to make--
My biggest theory is if
you document the journey
of finding the thing, that
when you find the thing,
you now have 10s of
thousands, thousands, hundreds
or hundreds of thousands.
And for very small
group millions of people
that are that have been
so invested in the journey
that when you open up your
bike shop, you fucking crush.
- No, I'm not and I think
one of the things I've come
to the conclusion of with me
is I don't know that there's a thing
or that thing.
- There shouldn't be.
- Right, so that's just not my--
it's just not my personality.
That's why I can easily--
And sourdough the only I'm reason selling
is because people like, "this
is fucking amazing bread.
"Why aren't you selling this?"
And I'm like, "I don't know,
"I just started doing this in the side."
- But you gotta make sure that it doesn't
become the desk job, right?
- Exactly, exactly.
And then when you are run--
- Or Tim, I apologize for interrupting
Or you love it for nine months,
and when it becomes a desk job,
you go into selling kite kits.
That's what I do.
I just do shit until I don't want--
- I'm a little 'cause I missed
a lot of the documenting
the journey so far.
- All you're doing now is
saying you're too old to do
a podcast just like with Diggnation.
Fuck the part that you
missed the documentation.
You got 50 more years of documenting.
- Yeah.
- You can't dwell, you have to do.
We can't dwell that you
missed all the documentation.
Episode one of the new
documentation starting tomorrow,
is just a recap of
everything we've all missed.
- And I think part of me is just
why haven't I done this before?
Right, and that's the core issue
that I'm still trying
to get to the bottom of,
just like that,
that fear of putting
yourself out there, right?
Like everybody on this
call probably knows that,
gets that a lot of people--
I mean, you get it but
you bust through it,
like your path and my path in 2005,
they're two different
things and that's okay.
- Here's the good news brother
in 2005 you and I took different paths.
I got good news for you.
Tomorrow our paths take
different paths in 2020
Dude, we're young, bro.
We're young, we obviously
got some grey hairs now
that we don't have those days.
But brother, we're fucking young.
- Yeah, I feel like--
- We're fucking young.
No we're young, brother,
do you have any 62 year old friends?
I mean that, do you have
any 62 year old friends?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Go face time them and
go have dinner with them
as soon as this is over.
We're young.
- Yeah, man.
- I don't know what to tell you dude.
Do you remember 20 years ago,
you know how young you felt 20 years ago.
- It's just this, is
just I mean it's funny
because I feel like I'm talking to you.
And I don't realize that
there's 10,000 people
who are watching this,
but then me putting up me
putting up an Instagram thing
and being like, "It's so fucked up, man."
I guess he's just gotta to
do and get numb to it, right?
But it's like that's the
protecting thing I built up.
- Were you scared to kiss girls?
- Yeah.
- Me too.
But then you eventually did it.
And then it became awesome.
- Yeah.
Sure.
- Were you scared to ride a bike?
- No, I don't think so.
- I was, I was like, "I'm
gonna fucking skin my knee!"
Like I was so fucking
scared of skinning my knee.
And then I started riding the bike.
- What about the first
time you post a content?
- That came different, that came easy.
Just like there's some people--
But here's the good news.
But for a lot of people posting content
is the scary thing like I was with bike
but for them they're like
you're scared to ride a bike,
you're scared to kiss
a girl because a girl,
that was not easy but we got through it,
We got through it.
It's all fake, it's all the boogeyman,
it's why I said, "Fuck you
devil on the Instagram live.
And then you know--
- I'll punch you on the dick,
I liked that.
- And you know what's funny?
I know on the other end,
there's like some 68 year old grandma
from Mexico who's like,
"Oh my god, no, not Pablo he's in trouble,
he's gonna die."
And I'm like, "No, no,
no, it's fucking fake."
So many things are fake, so
many fucking things are fake.
The visions your parents had was fake.
Life isn't about being ultra
conservative, it's fake.
- No, it hasn't really
worked out for me either.
Right, like I tried to do the right thing
and the thing I should.
- But good news,
that's on you.
That's what, yeah, exactly.
As long as you--
Yeah, I could see it.
As long as you don't put
that on your parents.
As long as you don't put that on society.
Exactly. So now good news, we're young.
- All right, man.
- All right, brother.
- Give me some good homework.
Tell me what to do here.
- Make, make, make, make.
Honestly, I think listening
to the Diggnation thing,
just kind of listening.
I think one of the--
Listen it's proven in the data.
One of the greatest things
that ever came out of my mouth
was document don't create.
And I think you should start documenting,
I think tomorrow should be episode one,
comic book number one first album,
where we literally talk like
this and recap us completely.
I was a boy that born in Denver,
like give us--
- Just put it all like on
all the platforms.
- All, all, all the platforms
Which I already can tell
you know what to do.
So, yes.
And then the next day you're
like, alright, here it is.
We're documenting the
journey today's you day 21
of the Corona virus.
I've been baking this bread
like I told you about yesterday.
I'm gonna bake a fucking
cookie, see what happens.
So here we go.
Putting up the phone
and then that's just seven
minute YouTube video.
You making a fucking
chocolate chip cookie.
- (laughing) Sound funny really.
All right, brother.
- All right, brother.
Talk to you.
- I appreciate it.
- Take care.
Let's Keep it going, Dustin.
If you're watching right now on Facebook,
please take a photo
and post it on Twitter
and say hi, I'd like to follow
and retweet some of you.
And that would be fun.
That will be fun.
My man, what's good Ricky?
- Oh, what's up, Gary?
- What's up, man?
- These are my kids By the
way, they they wanna say hi.
- Hi ladies.
Hi, how are you guys?
Hi guys.
- I'm Ricky and Ariel.
Ariel, how are you Ricky and Ariel?
- Okay. Wanna say hi?
All right, they know about you
'cause I've been hearing you
for years and years.
- Thank you, Ricky.
- Since you started as Gary Vee,
and I've been just trying to just say hi,
I'm nervous right now.
- No worries, man.
I'm super flattered to
be on with you, bro.
- Quick, just backstory man.
I used to work for a school district.
I was getting very
complacent there I guess,
just got the system there
and my hobby was art,
my passion is art I should
say, but business too.
So once I came across your content
you gave me that permission literally man
that's the only way I can explain it
you know What I mean--
- Ricky thank you so much bro.
I genuinely believe that I'm
a permission practitioner,
the reason I go after parents, the system,
school, other things
is because for hundreds of millions
that is the thing that's
keeping them in the box
and I want to be the person
they point to, to blame
or the shield like I'm
trying to get people
to air cover the permission to go
but you don't even know
how you saying that,
how much that means to me.
- Yeah, man that's my wife
right there too. (laughing)
(Ricky's wife cheering)
- Hi.
How are you?
(Ricky laughing)
- She also loves your content too.
So, man.
Yeah like I said you
gave me that permission
somehow through your content,
I hear everybody asking a question.
What was the question?
So I'm nervous man.
- Good news Ricky I'm not leaving.
- Dude, I didn't even leave
soon because I knew I was like,
man, I was gonna be next
and I didn't leave it
and I even recorded during the sign,
I'll send it to your
to your Twitter handle.
And by the way I was laughing man.
Like you're constantly innovating
and even in troubled times,
even through technology here.
- Ricky, and thank you for seeing it.
I'm at my best when it's the worst,
no sound, no problem because
I'm not scared Ricky,
'cause I'm not fucking scared.
Yeah, at the time you're
good at improvising.
That's why you're very good on stage
and I see a lot of your keynotes man,
I haven't met you in person.
I haven't been
to one of your (mumbles).
- Soon, soon.
- All this craziness, I'm
going to Fontana, California.
I mean Rialto, California sorry.
- Rialto, California, okay.
- Yeah so to be sure, man,
I know a lot of people
who wanna get in and whatever
but you give them a permission
to just don't regret
so what I did is I quit the job,
I literally quit a stable government job,
working for school district.
I started working with my brother.
He has an event business
called 909 Jumpers,
and I work with him and I helped him build
it up more branding 'cause I
do a lot of graphic design.
I'm an artist and we
basically grinded dirt,
you know how you said
for three years, man,
I just helped them.
Yeah, he's good at operations.
I was good at marketing.
We pushed it, pushed it, pushed it.
Then I got to a point where I was able
to open up my own tattoo studio.
And this is the tattoo studio
here showing this plug. (laughing)
- I love it.
- Iconic.
- And I got Vayner sports
(Ricky laughing)
- And so now at the point where
it's everything is halted.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because I'm most event
rental, event business
and pretty much one on
one person business.
Yeah. So I mean I understand
what you're gonna say,
"Just feel content right now."
- It's the real answer,
it's the real answer,
for example, I think this is right,
I'm sorry I don't know
tattoo culture well enough,
but I'm not immediate, you draw it out
and then you tattoo it, right?
- Yeah.
I'm drawing it right now.
- You have to document there bro.
- Yeah, I'm.
You have to you have to
post a tattoo drawing
every single day on every platform.
- Okay, yeah.
- You also have to sell stuff Saturday.
- Yeah, I'm looking at my house
what I can sell I'm hearing.
- You have to do that.
It's a nice thing to do, you'll clean up.
We all need to have less
shit and clutter anyway.
You're gonna also hone
your marketing skills.
You're gonna do something
on Craigslist and eBay
that then is gonna matter
for your tattoo business
in September because you
learned something about copy
or creative that led
to the sale of a bike.
Or that Apple screen in the background
or a book up there or whatever.
That's a big deal.
- Okay, all right.
I appreciate that.
That's very--
- What about LinkedIn?
Have you started creating
content or not yet, right?
Okay.
- I opened it up and then I just,
it's that first learning
stage and I'm like, ah,
I'll get back to it.
But you know what, I got
a lot time right now.
I'm gonna get back into it.
- Listen to me.
I know what you're gonna say
Gary, "Make content right?"
Is no different than a doctor saying,
"Eat healthy and exercise."
I know that everybody
watching right now knows
what I'm gonna say,
I'm fucking trying to
get fuckers to do you.
I'm open through one on one.
This is our moment and that makes you do?
I'm hoping somebody else's
name who's Sammy Gonzalez
who sees himself in you
right now in El Paso Texas,
like fuck it,
I'm just like, Ricky I'm gonna do.
So then all of a sudden
two people are gonna do
from this video.
Step by step, by step by
step, by step by step.
You understand?
- Yeah.
- Brother listen to me.
If you are not posting
tattoo content on Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram,
YouTube, Snapchat, LinkedIn
every day multiple times a day tic toc,
then you're fucking up.
- Well, you know what I did,
I did start a live class with my kids
'cause when I'm home and I'm like,
whoa, I have to attached
some of my clients
in the tattoo industry in my company,
our parents and then in the event rental
their parents as well.
So I figured they're home,
I like to draw, let's draw
and we did one session.
What was it?
Monday we did one session live class,
and we basically filmed
it live on Instagram
and we just started drawing
a Mickey Mouse character,
and I figure the parents are gonna show it
to their kids and that
brings me value to them.
I can't connect to them one on one,
but that's what I can offer right now.
- I love it.
Now, if you saw that
free deck that I put out
how to make 64 pieces of content
or the Gary Vee content model.
Now that video you need
to put into post that it,
learn how to do it and
make 12 pieces of content
from it not just one.
- Got it.
- Ricky the game is about volume, volume.
And when artists see your volume
they think quantity instead of quality
and it fucks them up.
- You're the man, man.
- It is quantity.
- For years I've been following you,
it means a lot made my day.
- Thank you, brother.
Take care.
- You too, man.
- Go back to the family.
Talk to you soon.
Guys, we'll try to sneak
a couple more in here
before we bounce out.
Let's see Trevor, Trevor Agnew.
You get a retweet.
Thank you for posting that photo.
Tom Draper's in the building.
- Hello.
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm doing good, how are you?
- What's your name?
- My name is Mivika, M-I-V-I-K-A.
- Hi Mivika.
Where are you from?
- So I'm from India, but
I'm in Virginia right now
in the US, yeah, I'm so excited
that we could get this call on
my family's watching from India.
They're super excited,
they've been popping on
live streaming
this on (mumbles).
- I love it.
I love it.
Hello everybody in India big shout out.
- I also wanted to show you this picture
that I made a few years
back and you retweeted it.
- That was you--
that was incredible.
Thank you for that.
I loved that.
- Thank you, I forgot.
- Thank you.
You're so talented.
What can I help you with?
- So right now I did
my undergrad in the US
and I'm on a one year visa in
the US that ends September.
And I plan to go back
and help my aunt on her fashion business.
She's an entrepreneur and
she's done amazing work,
like selling works through Facebook.
And I'm really excited to do it.
But then I also get a lot of
advice when people tell me
that this is the time for probably work
for a big company and get more exposure
to things like growth
and things like that.
But I feel in my gut that
this is what I wanna do
and I'm just so excited for it
and the only model that I have to do all
of this, is be awesome at you're doing.
So I have that structure down but--
and I believe in it, but it's also just,
I wanted your perspective on that.
- Talk it through, talk
it through I understand
what you actually asking at
the end there where you say,
"I have your model in mind."
Are you questioning if you
can execute against it?
Are you questioning what
else you could be doing?
What other angles like how does
that manifest in your brain?
- So I mean, I'm dedicated to doing this
for maybe the next 10 years of my life
but this stuff like,
"Oh, well I have the money,
I live with my family."
I'm totally fine with doing that as well.
It all works out for me in the end
but I do my dad invested all this money
to bring me to the US.
He paid for my education
and I do feel that pressure
but at the same time I feel like this.
- Is he concerned about you going into
the business with your aunt.
- He's very supportive of
me but he also worries that,
I don't know he has a feeling about
a small business versus a large one,
and he doesn't know how
to grapple with that,
and I've been sending him your videos,
and this is what he
said, he said it's fine.
So I came to you.
- I have a lot of empathy
and a lot of compassion
and a lot of respect for your dad.
And I understand, I really do.
I think the thing that I
keep trying to tell children,
especially from India,
and China and Russia,
because there's so many similarities
with different cultures
is your father loves you.
And at the end, so what he's worried about
is he in his soul, thinks that
the big business is safer,
and he wants to protect you.
And he thinks he also probably
thinks we've also made
this investment in your education.
So like, it seems
practical and right to him,
unfortunately, for you, and
so many people in India,
in Asia, in parts of Europe.
Unfortunately, so many of those people
don't want to be engineers
or doctors or lawyers
and it leads to incredible unhappiness.
And I remind parents to look
at other parents who are older.
20-30 years ahead and I
go, look, look at them.
That's your family.
And that 43 year old
woman resents her parents
and they don't have a good relationship.
And it's not good.
And so here's what I would
tell you, a couple things.
Number one, this is why
youth is so incredible.
You can go work for your
aunt, spend eight years on it.
And at the end of the day, God forbid,
it's a quote, unquote failure, right?
'A' it's not a failure,
because you're gonna learn so much more
in a small entrepreneurial business
than you'll ever learn in a
big corporation, so much more.
Number two, it's not a failure,
because you're gonna
be uncomfortably young,
uncomfortably young, and
you have your degree,
and you'll have your own street
smarts and your conviction.
And you can always get
a job at a big company.
Big Companies are always
interested in hiring,
because they make they make
profit by having more people
if they know how to run their business.
So I think it's more, I would argue if you
and I and your dad became friendly,
we were having tea, which
Russians and Indians love to have.
And we were talking, I would say to him,
Father, interestingly enough,
I would argue that it's more practical
for her to go into the
startup with the aunt,
than it is for her to
go into a big company.
That big companies are in full control
and that could lead to her getting let go
during the Coronavirus versus navigating
plus let's look at her face.
She clearly has the passion and
conviction to give it a try.
I actually think that, I believe in that.
I believe in that truth.
- And he's listening right now
so he can hear everything you say.
- And father you can't
imagine how much respect--
I'm the byproduct of immigrant parents,
hard working parents, loving parents,
I have so much empathy and
compassion for parents.
A lot of times I say, "Fuck
what your mom thinks."
It's not because I don't have
compassion for the mother.
It's because I'm trying to give freedom
for the child so that
the mother and the child,
the father and child can have
a great relationship long term.
I watched so many parents
do to their children,
what their parents did to them.
And they should know better,
because they know they didn't like it
when their parents did it.
And money is not, money is not happiness,
happiness is happiness.
And we do not need things,
we do not need a lot of things small homes
and not food is more than enough.
And so always chase happiness,
especially the youth,
because it's practical
to get a job at 28-29
because many corporations,
the way the world's going
are gonna actually look at people
that did entrepreneurship and
SMB for their corporation.
A company that your father
would want you to go into
now in nine years, if
it fails, is more likely
to hire you not because
you went to a competitor
for nine years on your resume,
but because you are entrepreneurial
because the internet is
forcing entrepreneurship
to be a more important
variable within corporations.
- That's awesome.
I wanna squeeze in one more
thing before I have to leave.
So, four days before
the internship deadline
for your internship, I
thought about the one thing
I wanna do before I leave the US
and there's nothing more amazing
to me than working for you.
So I just want to tell you about
what I did to make that happen.
So I booked tickets to unify Las Vegas
which was supposed to
happen today coincidentally,
but it's also really
weird that I'm speaking
to you right now.
The second thing I did
was create 64 pieces
of content in four days challenge
for myself before the deadline,
and I knocked it out, I finished it,
I made a second video about it
and like shared it all over my Instagram.
And I emailed Girak, I
annoyed Brandon and Jason
sent it to all of them on their DMs,
they were really kind
enough to reply to me.
You don't have to reply to my emails,
although you're amazing.
And the main point that I'm
trying to tell you from that
was that the process itself
was so amazing to me.
I got so addicted to that,
that I started my own weekly playlist
from my other account
because I loved it so much.
And the second thing
is I just know how much
your employees mean to you.
And it makes complete sense to me.
So if it doesn't work out, it's fine.
But I just wanna tell
you that I have good work
and if I could possibly
work for free at any point,
what intended--
- Listen to me, send
me an email right now.
Send me an email let me look at it.
It's gary@vaynermedia.
- I'll do that.
Yeah, thank you so much.
- I'm really proud of you.
You are an incredible young woman.
I'm a big buyer of you,
You cheered my life, you're
changing my life right now.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so much.
- I couldn't think of a better way to end
Tea with Gary Vee on
this beautiful Friday.
I'm debating going on tomorrow.
- [Dustin] The team actually
was asking if you could sit
this one person in,
I think you're gonna
really like this person
but it's up to you of course.
- Hey, Dustin, we're gonna have
to do this person on tomorrow.
Because I have to do
something with my kids
and that's just the way it is.
So I love everybody.
Tea with GaryVee.
I hope you enjoyed it.
It was an interesting day.
Facebook Live and Instagram, Facebook.
Dustin, thank you for persevering.
Thank you for everybody.
I love you guys so much.
A couple things one, please share this.
I want a lot more people tomorrow.
We'll update you guys later tonight.
What time tomorrow if tomorrow?
Tomorrow might be wine
with Gary Vaynerchuk.
We'll figure it out.
But definitely back Monday morning.
And very likely I'll see
you over the weekend.
I love you guys all so much.
Please go flash.
Or 10,000 if you're watching right now,
clash Twitter right now
Gary Vee and tell me what you
thought about today's episode.
And I love you guys so much.
See you.
Oh, and hook up my paps
winetext.com if you drink wine
and you buy it on the internet
or at a bullshit supermarket
and you're overpaying for it,
go to winetext.com and sign
up for my dad's service.
It means a lot to me and
it's been a lot of fun.
I'm enjoying that as well.
So see you later.
Bye bye.